Hello Internet
Welcome to Film Theory, the show that knows
that a picture is worth a thousand words.
The drawings show them what really
happened. And what did you draw a
yellow rabbit hitting the subscribe button?
They can see you now. Well great,
that is the point of the subscribe
button after all. Thanks, Abby
Finally, finally, it's happened after
eight agonizingly long years in development
Hell hopping from studio to studio
director to director the Five Nights
at Freddy's movie is finally
out for you to go see right now.
And man has this been a commercial hit.
As of the writing of this script just
one weekend into release, the movie's made over
$152 million dollars at the box office,
more than seven times its own budget.
And that's despite being available
to stream on Peacock where, oh wait,
it's also the most-viewed movie on Peacock ever.
Suck on that, My Big Fat Greek Wedding Three.
It's also Blumhouse's most
successful opening weekend to date,
which means that more people are turning out
to see Springtrap wielding
his knife and Michael Myers.
Maybe now Hollywood will finally bother
to get the name of this thing, right.
And his other movie Friday Nights
at Freddy's comes to theaters and
streaming on Peacock October
27th. FIVE Nights at Freddy's.
What did I say? Friday Nights. It's been eight
or nine years since I first met
Scott Cawthorn, who created this.
Why do we get it wrong? Or not.
Who cares. Forget 'em. This thing was
made for the fans from Sparky the dog
to dream theory to "it's just a theory." You bet
it is. And today we're getting
back to those Theorist roots. Today
we're theorizing about the actual
movie and boy is there a lot to
talk about here. True story, after the movie
I basically locked myself in the room with Lee and
Tom, the Film and Game Theory Creative Directors,
and we busted out our trusty whiteboard
to figure out exactly what was going on
in the movie and where the story was gonna head in
the future. 'Cause there were just a lot
of details left hanging. What was
up with the balloon boy figurine?
How's no one freaked out by the fact that
there are bodies in those animatronics?
Wasn't this like the most
structurally unsound table
fort of all time? That last one perhaps
the biggest mystery of them all. Today
we're gonna be looking at all the Easter eggs,
secrets, and hidden lore from the
movie then comparing those to other
parts of the franchise, both the
books and the games, in order to
predict where the story of the FNAF 2 movie is
gonna go years before they actually make it.
So that's our one job for today.
But before we get to it, I also
have to shout out our brand new
line of officially licensed FNAF Theorywear.
That's two jobs. Yeah, I guess
you're right, Vanessa. It is two jobs
Anyway, let me tell you guys
these are some of the most fun,
unique items that we've ever
done and not only are the designs
fun, let's be honest,
there's also a lot of just FNAF
stuff out there in the market,
which is also why we wanted to
create the highest quality clothing
out there to complete with rubber patches,
embroidered detailing, soft teddy fleece.
This stuff isn't just FNAF merch. It is
FNAF apparel. Oh in case you were wondering,
every item in this collection had to be approved
by, Mr. Scott "Cawthorn" himself. And look,
we're so tight I even know how
to pronounce his name right.
And in this collection, we've
got something for everyone.
Do you like graphic tees? Check out the retro band
t-shirts featuring Freddy
purple guy, and of course
Muuuuuusic Man.
You want something a little bit more
subtle? The all-over prints of the
confetti tee and employee tee will
make you look good without screaming
"I'm a FNAF fan" in everyone's face.
If you're in the mood to
do some cute FNAF-bounding,
the Chica cheer bundle's got you covered
with a Chica-themed top, skirt with
underscore, and high socks. And, of course,
we've got jackets. Oh boy we've got jackets.
It's not a Theorywear collection unless there
are some killer jackets in here.
And we had fun with this batch.
You have the FNAF high varsity jacket
inspired by Chica's Anime Adventures
and Ultimate Custom Night with colorful
patches of all your favorite characters
down the faux leather sleeves and a class of 1983
embroidered patch on the back for obvious reasons.
There is only one thing
that could possibly go wrong
Yeah, and that's falling in
love with another jacket like
our withered fleece complete with 3d
animatronic endoskeleton detailing.
That's a Endo-02 to be specific.
So make sure you put that one
on your next timeline. And while
the outside is nice and soft and
fluffy, the inside is waterproof
and purple in case you feel like flipping the
entire thing inside out and sporting
the franchise's most notorious color.
And lastly probably the most fun piece we've ever
done the Monty jacket. It
is faux alligator leather
that's glammed out to the max with bright yellow
interior and sharp metal studs
to show that you're the raddest
reptile on the block. Any guitar
playing bunnies better watch
their backs when you're wearing this
one. If any of this has caught your
eye and you want to show off both
your love of FNAF and theorizing,
go check out our official FNAF collection over at
Theorywear.com. That's T
H E O R Y W E A R dot com.
And now with that shameless
self-promotion out of the way
let's just hop into the theory,
shall we? So to begin we should
point out that we already do
have some vague idea where
the sequel's gonna head. In an interview
with variety, FNAF director Emma
Tammi explained that the first movie was tied
to the first game so a second film would
likely tie into a second game, which duh
kind of goes without saying. But also it should
probably make our lives easy, right? Ehh.
Not quite. As we mentioned in
our first prediction theory,
the strategy for the movieverse seems to be
taking iconic bits and pieces from across
the entire franchise, games, books, fan theories,
even hoaxes, and distilling it all down
into the most recognizable version of FNAF
there is. That's how we got Mike Schmidt from FNAF
1 hanging out with Vanessa from Security Breach
fightin' Springtrap from FNAF 3 and
saving Abby from getting stuck into
a spring-locked version of Ella
from the Silver Eyes novel with an
ending that was ripped straight
out of the fourth closet.
It is literally FNAF the smoothie,
everything dumped into a blender chopped up
and then poured back out onto the big screen.
So yeah while it did follow the same
broad strokes as the first game,
five nights in the FNAF 1 pizzeria with ghost kids
in suits, it is definitely not the same story.
It's also important to note the
changes to the story that have
been added in. One example has
to be the time that these movies
take place. It's widely accepted that the
FNAF 1 video game takes place somewhere around
1993 and, yet, in this scene from the movie we see
a date on a security camera that reads April 6th,
2000, about seven years later.
Another big example, though
we've long theorized that the story of the
original FNAF games takes place in Utah,
that is not the case in the film.
In the film during the scene where
aunt Jane is confronting Mike at Abby's school,
her lawyer hands Mike some
family court paperwork. If
you pause and read the fine print on the documents
you'll find the URL MNcourts.gov,
which is the official website for
the Minnesota judicial system.
Additionally, we can see a phone
number with the area code 651
which is connected to the
St. Paul area and eastern
suburbs of Minnesota. And, get this, I kid you not
there's a small town in this area code
named Afton. You cannot make that up.
Honestly, I wouldn't be surprised if Scott moved
the entire movie to Minnesota
just for that change alone.
Lastly, there's also this decal
on Vanessa's police cruiser:
GFPD. PD stands for police department
That part's pretty darn obvious.
But then what about the GF?
Well, honestly that could stand for
any city or township with those same
initials from Grand Forks to
Glen Falls to Great Falls.
But included in that list is Granite
Falls just two hours west of St
Paul, whose cop cars, at least
according to the website,
follow the exact same black and white
color pattern that we see in the movie.
Speaking of clues from the cars
that are seen throughout the movie
we can also reasonably assume that
Mike's brother Garrett was kidnapped
in the early '80s based on this
shot from Mike's dream sequence.
By taking the rear end of William Afton's
car here and reverse image searching for it
we're able to identify this as a
Ford Fairmont Futura, specifically
the model is coming from between 1980 and 1983.
You can immediately see the
connections here between
the unique vertical taillight
design and the boxy body shape.
But why then does that matter?
Well Mike's brother Garrett is
likely the first child that Afton
abducted and killed. In Mike's dream flashbacks
we very clearly see Garrett
holding a toy airplane as
he's being taken away in the back of Afton's car.
And where do we see that airplane again?
When Vanessa reveals Afton to be her father.
She's holding the same airplane.
That right there that is cold,
gifting toys from your victims to your
daughter. But not only is it gross,
it's also helpful because it lets
us put together a rough timeline.
You see Afton and Vanessa are clearly in a
still-operational pizzeria in this photograph,
which means it had to have been taken
before the other kids went missing
causing Freddy's to shut down.
In other words Garrett was the
first of Afton's victims that we currently know
of. And that right there that's
important because in the games
Afton's first victim and the one
most closely associated with his
car goes on to possess The
Puppet, a marionette-esque
character that serves as a protector and
guide to all the other spirit children.
It's the first victim that
gives gifts and gives life
to the other animatronics after their murders.
We see this possession happening in
FNAF 6's security puppet minigame.
Notice the tire tracks out there in the rain.
We see the exact same event from
a different angle in FNAF 2.
Notice that cool purple car. From there
the rest of FNAF 2's hidden minigames
then show us the puppet trying to
protect the other dead children
from Afton. And when it can't
the puppet decides to bring them
to life in the form of animatronics.
S-A-V-E-T-H-E-M
The robotic voice here is spelling out
"save them." Does it sound familiar?
It should. That same robotic voice appears
at the very end of the movie's credits
C-O-M-E-F-I-N-D-M-E
Once the whole thing wraps the
voice has spelled out "come find
me" in the exact same way that the puppet
communicated to the player
in the FNAF 2 minigames.
And who needs to be found in the movie? Garrett.
See the fact that they never resolved
what exactly happened to Garrett was a
big thing that stuck out to me when I was watching
this thing. After all it was Mike's entire
motivation and his only clear outright
connection to both Afton and Vanessa. His fate is
definitely gonna come up again in the sequel and
all the signs are pointing to the
puppet from the FNAF 2 video game
What's more did you notice the music
that was playing during that section?
It's a music box, another nod to
the puppet who in the games is kept
calm by constantly winding a music box. In short
Garrett is possessing the puppet in
this world and here he is literally
trying to tell Mike and the
audience to come find him in
the sequel. But stop for a minute and consider
the method of Afton's crime here.
It is different from all the rest
He's out in nature. He kidnaps
Garrett and presumably leaves
him alive longer than his normal victims
He keeps the kids toy and
then gives it to his daughter.
They're even in a completely
different state. Unlike the
rest of Afton's crimes where he just
lures kids to the back of the pizzeria
and kills them, here things feel premeditated.
They feel personal and that would align
with both the games in the books where
Afton's first murder isn't just a random killing
it's targeted against one person
his business partner and the
original builder of the animatronics, Henry.
In fact in the novel trilogy
Afton does the exact same thing
that he does in the movie.
He kidnaps Henry's daughter Charlie before
ultimately killing her. Basically all signs
point to Garrett not just being a random victim
but rather to him being the son of Afton's partner
and rival Henry the man who helped
Afton build all of the animatronics.
See as I was piecing together
the details from the movie
I started to notice something. The Afton
and Schmidt families from the movie seem
awfully close to the family structures
from the games except in reverse.
You see in the game series
we know that Afton has himself three
children: Michael, crying child,
and Elizabeth. The oldest son Michael
plays a prank as a kid which gets
his younger brother killed in the
iconic bite of 1983. From there on
Mike becomes obsessed with atoning for his mistake
eventually becoming a security guard and releasing
the spirit of his brother into the afterlife.
Then there's Elizabeth who eventually
gets trapped and dies inside of Baby,
a suit that is increasingly looking
to be a spring-lock animatronic.
Now let's check out the Schmidt
family over in the movie
You have again a family of three two boys and a
girl. Mike the older brother is a
security guard who's obsessed with
atoning for the time that he got his
younger brother Garrett kidnapped and
killed. Then there's Abby who's nearly
trapped and killed inside the Ella
Suit a spring-lock animatronic.
They literally match one for one.
Meanwhile Afton in the movie seems
to have himself only one daughter,
Vanessa, just like Henry had himself
one daughter, Charlie, in the game.
So if they've switched dynamics
that can make Mike's dad here the
representative of Henry Emily
from the games. Her mom died
a little while back. And dad,
he couldn't handle it, so...
They leave Mike's dad's fate vague.
To me looks like it was deliberately
done in case they ever wanted
to bring Mike's dad back into
the story in a role similar to Henry's. But
perhaps most interesting of all if you
look in the background of the employee
training video you can see a man who looks very
similar to Mike's dad working on the animatronics
just like Henry would have
done in the games canon.
This is also as far as I can
tell an uncredited performance,
but one look at Mike's dad, this
guy from the training video,
and the way that Henry's portrayed in
places like the character encyclopedia,
it shows a visual design connection
between the three of them.
But not only would this connection
fit with the established game lore,
it would also explain why William Afton
recognizes Mike. Early in the movie
we see Afton have a moment of recognition
when he reads Mike's last name, Mr. Michael...
But according to US Census data, there's
around a hundred and sixty six thousand
people with the last name Schmidt here in the US.
So either this is just a case of pure
movie coincidence, or William recognizes
not only the last name Schmidt,
but Mike Schmidt specifically in the general
age range that his partner's son would be.
That's why he's so sure that this is
someone from his past. More evidence
for this? The fact that William
knows that Mike has a brother
without it ever being addressed.
This is perfect. First I killed
your brother. Now I kill you.
Sure, we can assume the spirit children told him.
The little ones told me you have a sister.
Or maybe Vanessa.
But that's a bit less satisfying
than him just knowing and taking
out his vendetta against every member
of the Schmidt family. And for those
of you saying that Henry's last
name is Emily, it might be;
but that's never actually
been officially confirmed.
We've always thought it was a bit bizarre to
have as a last name. And, let's be honest,
it could just as easily be Charlie's middle name
Charlotte Emily Schmidt. But
last let's talk about William.
You'll notice that I just pulled
the line that indicates that the
spirits talked to William throughout this movie,
which is a very important detail.
In fact, if you notice they really gave Afton
a lot of explicit control over
what the spirits are doing here.
See while he seems to understand
what was happening in the games
it never seemed like he could outright
control the animatronics. In the books,
it's a little bit different.
He eventually is able to control the animatronics,
but not until the last novel
of the trilogy. Here, though,
he seems to understand all of it from
the get-go. They tell him about Abby.
He understands the importance
of the pictures on the wall.
What have you done. And as the springlocks
in his suit are going off and he's dying?
What does he do?
He basically looks directly in the camera says
his catchphrase "I always come back"
and puts on the spring-trap helmet.
Why? What sense would that make?
Well, it's a pretty clear indication that this
Afton explicitly knows how possession works
and it involves being completely put inside of the
suit like this. Putting on that helmet
is basically Afton accepting his fate
knowing that he'll be back able to possess
the suit and survive. So right here
we have ourselves a smarter Afton who
is years further in his understanding
of the spiritual world than
either the Afton in the games
or the books which leads me to
this... an animatronic buried
in the parts-and-service room of the pizzeria.
One that you can't see in the movie
but you can see in the behind-the-scenes
footage from Dawko during his tour of the
movie set. An animatronic
with rounded human skull,
silver eyes, and human teeth. While, this
could just be background set dressing
I don't think that's the case. If this is truly
an Afton who understands the power
of agony in granting eternal life,
if this is an Afton who has gone so far as
to build a Freddy torture chair for
extracting remnant from his victims,
I'm thinking his experiments with
building passable robotic humans
has already begun. This isn't just me
playing the robot Gregory game again,
it is the only explanation for
the parts-and-services room to
have an animatronic with human
teeth and realistic human head
proportions and eyes. And above it hanging
from the top of the shop a robotic hand
with five fully articulating
fingers and human proportions.
No other animatronic in this series
fits this sort of description.
Does this mean he's already
built a humanoid or is this
just an early phase of his experiments? Unclear.
But it does give a bit more credit to
Vanessa's bloodless stab wound at the
end of the movie being more than just an excuse
to get itself a pg-13 rating.
My real guess, though,
is that there's a robot Garrett walking around and
that he'll be the reveal at the end
of the movie just like Charlie the
Puppet is revealed to be a robot at the end
of The Fourth Closet, a world-shattering
revelation for Mike as he comes to terms with
the nature of his brother and his father's weird
creations before the final movie where he's
tasked with having to burn it all down.
Honestly, the pieces are in place for us.
Or not. All the next movie has to do is drop
a Markiplier cameo and then show
me a clip of Mangle and I'm in.
But hey one last reminder to check
out our incredible officially licensed
FNAF merch. Grab them while they are remaining.
Remaining? Rem-nanting? Last thing you want is the
agony of knowing that they've
sold out when you wanted one.
And as always my friends remember, it's
all just a theory a Film Theory and cut.